Steven, Cade, congratulations.
You guys have made it into
the third and final round
of this competition, and
let me say this-- you
fellas can forge, man.
You guys really
brought your A game.
But you're going to
have to step it up,
because now we're sending
you back to your home forges
to recreate this iconic
weapon from history.
The Rooster Head
French Pioneer Sword.
[rooster crowing]
Gentlemen, good luck.
We'll see you in four days.
CADE: We're here in
Loranger, Louisiana,
and I'm ready to get going.
We're going to try to
whack this piece of metal
out and get it into profile.
I start off at the
tip because it's
probably the most demanding, and
I work my way back from there.
Traditionally, these blades
have a slight saber type bend
in them, so I heat
it up, and I whack
it over the end of the anvil.
I'm very tired, but I got
the forging of my blade done.
While I'm waiting
for it to cool off,
I'm just going to go and work
on my rooster head pommel.
I found this chicken head.
I thought it would be perfect.
So I can make the mold
to cast with bronze.
It wasn't able to
heat treat, but
what I didn't get done on the
blade, I got down on my mold.
So I still feel
like I'm on track.
STEVEN: So it's the
morning of day two,
and I've got a lot
of work to do today.
I have to cut my saw
teeth into the back.
Now I'm ready for
the heat treat.
This is proving a little
more difficult than I thought
it'd be to get an even heat.
This plate isn't all that hard.
[bleep],, can't turn in a
blade that's half hard.
I am screwed.
So here we go again.
I'm going to sit here
and re-quench this,
and re-straighten
this until it's hard.
There's some flames.
That's what we want to see.
I file test it, skating my
glass That's a hard blade.
CADE: I'm starting off the
day grinding my fullers.
Don't know how
that's going to go.
One danger of having
double sided fullers--
you can grind straight
through your blade.
And so I just kind
of go down the blade
and check, and make
sure I'm not doing that.
I've got to sharpen
the saw back, too.
I don't know what they're
going to test this thing on.
Hopefully it'll hog
away some stuff.
Now that I'm done with that,
it is time to heat treat.
It's hard.
Today I'm going to
try to conquer casting.
This is my absolute first
time doing any casting,
so hopefully I can
get it figured out.
I want to cast three pieces.
There's the guard piece,
handle, and then there's
the rooster headed pommel.
My first casting is
just a piece of bronze
that's going to be the guard
with the up-swept quillons.
All right.
That's way more than
enough for a guard.
I have the guard cast, which
I'm pretty happy about.
I have the handle cast,
then I got this rooster.
I can see an eye, I can see the
detailed feathers on this side.
Friggin' sweet.
This is a lot denser and heavier
than I thought, which I'm
happy about because my blade
is super forward heavy,
and I want that
balance point to just
get farther back on the blade.
Going into day four, I have
the three pieces of my handle.
So my day tomorrow is
going to be tedious.
Finish work.
CADE: It's the
morning of day four,
and today it's just
putting it all together.
I casted my rooster
head and my guard.
And if I may say, this
is one bomb chicken head.
[rooster crows]
Look at that bad boy.
Cock-a-doodle-doo.
Handle comes next.
That's about it.
Everything's
looking pretty good.
I got a sword!
All right, bladesmiths.
Your blades look lovely,
but are they deadly?
I'm going to take your
weapons to deliver
some lethal cuts and slashes
on this goat carcass.
It's time to find out if
they're ready for a cockfight,
or are they going
to play chicken?
Steven, you're up first.
Are you ready for this?
Let's do it.
[chopping]
[music playing]
All right, Steven, let's
talk about your sword here.
It's beautiful looking,
and it's a heavy sword.
But that lends itself
to deliver very
deep cuts with every swing.
And more importantly,
it will kill.
All right, Cade, your turn, sir.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
[chopping]
[music playing]
All right, Cade, let's
talk about your sword here.
Your handle construction
fits perfectly in my hand.
Now, your edge is pristine, no
glints, no rollings whatsoever.
And most importantly,
it will kill.
All right, gentlemen,
welcome to the strength test.
The log chop.
Now, to test the strength
and overall durability
of your blades, I'll be
chopping on this log.
All right, Steven,
you're up first.
You ready for this?
Let's do it.
[chopping]
[music playing]
Right.
First off, Steven, nice
job on the castings.
They're nicely done.
Your handle is about
an inch too long.
It allows my hand to
travel around a lot.
Your blade took no
damage whatsoever.
Good job.
Thanks.
All right, Cade,
you're up next.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
[chopping]
[music playing]
All right, Cade, your
blade is in good condition.
No rolls, no chips.
Still sharp as it
was when I started.
Good job.
All right, bladesmiths,
this is the sharpness test--
the scarecrow saw and slice.
To test the saw
backs on your weapon,
I'll be sawing into
the wooden dowels.
Then I'll test the edge
by cutting the watermelon
and a sugar cane bundle.
Steven, you're up first.
You ready?
Let's do it.
[sawing]
[music playing]
All right, Steven, let's
talk about your saw back here.
Once it gets started,
it starts to saw.
It works.
It's a functional
saw back in there.
You're able to dig
into the dowel.
Your edge is sharp.
No issues cutting
on the watermelon,
and the weight alone is going to
just chop that whole thing off.
Overall, sir, it'll cut.
Thank you.
All right, Cade, your turn.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
[sawing]
[music playing]
All right, Cade, the saw back.
These teeth are sharp.
Even at the start,
it already digs in.
A couple of slices in
there, it's already digging
right into the wooden dowel.
Your edge-- no
issues whatsoever.
Cuts through the watermelon,
and cuts the rest
of the sugar cane bundles.
Overall, sir, it'll cut.
Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths, the
weapons tests are complete
and the judges literally
had to weigh the details.
The new "Forged in
Fire" champion is--
Cade.
Congratulations, you are the
"Forged in Fire" champion.
Steven, your blade is 2 pounds
heavier than Cade's blade,
making it less wieldy.
Additionally, your handle is
a little bit out of proportion
with the blade, and it's for
that reason that you cannot be
the "Forged in Fire" champion.
Come on forward, my friend.
Even though I feel
somewhat defeated right now,
I'm still proud
of what I've done,
and I'm proud of
what I turned in.
- [inaudible].
- Thank you.
You're a great competitor.
Thank you.
Steven, this cast
is [inaudible]..
I'm not going to
say I'm going to go
home and start making
swords, but I did
really enjoy the whole process.
And it also taught me what
I could do in a short amount
of time, Not that it's my best
work, but I'm proud of myself
for not giving up there.
Cade, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion,
and that is a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
How do you feel right now?
Cock-a-doodle-doo?
[laughter]
Good job, my friend.
You made a fine Rooster
Headed French Pioneer Sword.
Come on forward
and shake our head.
I am super psyched right now.
I am so proud of
myself, and I thank God
that I had this opportunity.
I gotta keep working
hard, and keep on trying
to climb that ladder, you know?
10 grand is college funds.
[laughs]